so hello everyone good morning
um thanks to the organizers for having
having us and it's good to be back um I
think I was at this conference three
years ago the last time we were in
person it's nice to see your faces again
um so I'm going to talk about Ibis uh
really quick just a little about me my
name is Gail Forsyth I work at Voltron
data on the left are the places you can
find me on the internet and on the right
are some things I've done which I've
just included here to say that if you're
thinking about making a change and you
aren't sure if you can you definitely
can
um so Ibis
is a lightweight python library for a
data wrangling and it was built by all
of these lovely people uh and some more
um but before I talk about Ibis I just
want to get a quick show of hands has
anybody ever had to translate data
analysis from pandas to Pi Spark
yeah or like prototype something in
pandas and thrown it over a wall to a
data engineer so they could re-implement
it or maybe you were the data engineer
and something was thrown at you or you
used parquet as a cross-language
serialization format
um so like pandas and Pi spark here are
just representative you can fill in the
tools and the left and the right there
for any number of things
um I know these tools are bad quite the
opposite right it's just that uh well
and none of these things even are bad
except like throwing stuff over wall
that's that's bad
um but what it is representative of is
that in the pi data stack there are two
assumptions which is that the first time
is that your data is local and that your
data fits in memory and that is a pretty
common assumption made by almost all of
these tools
uh and so what does that look like
well it might look something like this
if you have um your local laptop and
some some kind of remote engine uh and
you're gonna connect to that engine and
you're gonna say hey do you have some
table called ratings Maybe
and then you're going to slurp up that
entire table
and then you're going to load it and
parse the types and perform your
analysis right
um so there are potentially some issues
with this and this may be totally fine
also but potentially one if you're out
of memory you are out of luck right and
this doesn't scale particularly well
um and again pandas and postgres here
are representative I mean pandas is the
800 pound gorilla in the room um uh the
thing so this pattern also treats the
remote engine like it's a data store and
it is but that's not all that those
engines can do
um and this is a pattern that shows up
over and over again in the pi data stack
especially in relation to for lack of
better word the Enterprise
uh and so what I call this is the the pi
data translation problem which is in
practice the tool chain that's available
for local development on like an
Enterprise laptop is different from what
the eventual production job is going to
run against now these two boxes here are
far from exhaustive and yes like some
tools in there can move into one or the
other one
um but by and large there is a gap
and we want to bridge that Gap
um and one of the tools that nominally
promises to remove this hurdle is SQL
so we need to talk about SQL uh you know
the structured query language it's been
around for a long time you've probably
written at least a little bit of it but
most importantly it is absolutely
everywhere
and it is between you and the data
and however it's not without its
problems right so
some pros and cons always a good sign
when all the pros have caveats and you
know uh so SQL is standardized uh kind
of not really we'll talk more about that
and it's concise
uh the cons it's effectively untestable
that conciseness sometimes means that
it's inscrutable uh and it fails at
runtime
um but does it solve the translation
problem
no it doesn't
um so the claim is just write SQL you
can always execute SQL and there's no
divide between Dev and prod so let's say
in that instance you have your local
machine let's say you do in your text
editor or some CLI tool but you somehow
conjure a query
and then you connect to the engine you
send the query
it executes the query and you get the
results back
um this is fine uh but a couple of
things one this is not a very tight Loop
when you're doing a exploratory work
uh and secondly you may not be allowed
to run queries against prod when you're
doing exploratory data analysis there
can often be restrictions on when you're
allowed to connect what you're allowed
to run
um so maybe instead you get like a local
sample right you could do this with like
sqlite or duckdb or something and now
you've got this tight loop on your
laptop and you can kind of iterate there
on a sample of the data now you're not
Conjuring a query you've actually run it
like great so now you know you have a
kind of a little more confidence that
it's going to run then you send it over
to the big engine
you send it over it executes it Returns
the results right problem solved
um
there are a few issues here right so
let's look at a different translation
problem right so let's uh say we have a
simple data cleaning task right so we've
got the table on the left the table on
the right and the left is what's in the
data store and it's been ingested
incorrectly right so you've got some T
const some standard key you have an
average rating you have the number of
votes and it's just all been ingested as
strings and like sure you could petition
to have this change and fixed Upstream
but realistically that's not going to
happen and so what you want to do is
just do some casting right the average
vote average rating should be a float
and the number of votes should be an
integer
so that's a pretty straightforward task
to do right couple of lines
um
so if you write this in sqlite you get
the above you write it in postgres you
get the below right this is a very
simple task and already things have
diverged right now this is not an
insurmountable divide and what I'm
talking about is you know the data types
have different names even though they're
referring to the same thing
um it's not insurmountable we'll come
back to it but the general takeaway here
is that you definitely want to avoid
maintaining two versions of nearly the
same script if possible like someone's
going to change one of them and not the
other one something's going to go wrong
it's going to go badly
um SQL also has what I call a
parameterization problem
um which is like are you running one
bigquery or are you running like many
smaller queries right
um and like how are you running those
thousand queries how are you generating
them like you want to grab the top 10
movies but also let's say ones that have
certain keywords in them and maybe
that's on the basis of which user you
have
um so you have to generate all that SQL
are you saving them out as like
individual SQL queries how are you
batching over the execution uh what
happens when someone's keywords are like
none and null uh like you know you're
going to find that out when it fails at
runtime
um there's a another issue uh which is
that I want to write my stuff in Python
I like Python and I want to use it and
there's a the final issue uh which is
that I don't want to write SQL um like
SQL can be very concise some operations
are really hard to spell and you can
definitely do anything in SQL but do you
want to learn about recursive comment
table Expressions I guarantee the answer
is no you really don't
um so what is
a solution to this problem
presented with translation problem
parameterization problem we want to use
Python we don't want to write a bunch of
SQL
some people will say I know I'll
generate strings we've all done this
we can forgive ourselves
um so let's recall this simple example
we're going to string sequify this right
so all we need to do pick up a couple of
format Fields maybe we write like a
small little mapping or a little helper
function you know look look at what
engine we're using when I say float what
I mean is real or I mean you know
whatever double Precision or what have
you and so this is fine this is very
straightforward it's okay but remember
you've got the translation problem which
is that first off the function names
when your two engines may be different
they probably are or the function exists
in one engine and not in the other one
like maybe you have a mode function and
your other engine doesn't have a mode
function
um function argument order can differ so
like you take the log of x to some base
B does X come first in the arguments or
does B first there's no like right
answer to that question so like who
knows
um SQL engines have optimized versions
of certain common functions you want to
take advantage of those otherwise you're
leaving a bunch of performance on the
table
and I haven't even talked about like
date and time syntax or string
concatenation rules or null Behavior
like there is a lot of Divergence here
um
you have the parameterization problem
still uh so like templating can ease
that if the parameters are
straightforward but they usually aren't
for any like big problem you're doing
and like eventually something's going to
end up conditioned on some other part of
the parameter or like some other thing
that's happening in your query it's just
going to get more and more complicated
and then there are outside factors that
may impact what you're actually trying
to build here right and these are some
things you may have heard from people
um and this query that started off so
simple and straightforward is going to
grow and grow and grow until you end up
with something maybe like this
right so you're selecting the title of
the movie you're doing that initial cast
we've got that down
um but now you like aren't sure maybe
you're using like two different tables
because you want to be running through
different sets of ratings and movies
um if you're changing the tables you're
probably changing the join Keys you got
to parameterize that and substring
matching definitely changes between
engines so you're gonna need to have a
special case for how to do the substring
matching which means you're
parameterizing your parameters which is
a bad place to be you probably don't
remember because no one does when to use
backticks or quotes to escape spaces and
is it single quotes or is it double
quotes and this is just terrible it's
terrible no one wants to do this
and I'll say of course this is a
caricature but who here can say with
full confidence that something like this
would not happen at their workplace
for the video there are no hands up in
the room okay so presented with
something as which is the worst code
I've ever written in my life ever
um you might say gross I'm not going to
use SQL and that would be a very valid
response here but remember it is
everywhere and a point that I overlooked
a lot when I was really getting started
with all this stuff is that computer
scientists have been working on these
problems for 50 years and they have made
some incredibly fast execution engines
and if you're not taking advantage of
them you're leaving just a Preposterous
amount of performance on the table
so where does that leave us SQL
standards are not standard uh SQL can be
a little convoluted string generation is
a bad idea full stop
um but we still want to write our
analytics and python so what if instead
of generating strings you write concise
python code that type checks and
eventually generates strings
and that's Ibis so Ibis is a lightweight
python library for data wrangling
has a data frame API for python we have
interfaces too we like to say dozens of
query engines dozen one doesn't
um and a deferred execution model which
I'll talk about in a second for any R
stats people who have snuck in uh
welcome and also this is similar in
spirit to D fly or DB player
um so deferred execution what does that
look like if we kind of go back to our
local remote or local prod divide again
um so you have Ibis on the left you've
got your remote engine on the right
and you connect to it and you say hey I
think you've got a table called ratings
and you get back instead of all the data
is just the schema right the column
names and the types
and now on your local you can build up a
query which is like going to be
represented as an expression of the
stuff you want to do
you can be validated on the without
knowing anything about the data other
than the types and the names of the
columns then we can compile it into SQL
send that SQL query over the engine have
it execute that query and then we get
our results back
so a couple of nice things fall out of
this uh for the one thing the machine on
the left could be like a first
generation Raspberry Pi and you're fine
like you don't need that machine to be
fast because that's not where the heavy
lifting is happening the machine on the
right can be a beast and then things
just get faster so your execution is
going to happen at the speed of the back
end not of your local machine and almost
always the thing on the right here is
closer to the data and has a much bigger
pipe to get it so like you're just going
to avoid trying to like you know pull
down many many terabytes of data over
your home internet connection
um
another thing that can come out of this
is that maybe you actually don't need to
talk to the execution engine to get that
first bit of information right like
there could be some separate metadata
store that's providing you with column
names and data types and then the only
time you need to talk to the execution
engine is when you're ready to execute
something
um so this can be you know if there's
contention around you know uh like
quotas on what you can run on that or
maybe it's expensive or maybe something
but you can build up a lease a
preliminary workflow without ever
talking to the execution engine until
you're ready to go and you'll know that
at the very least when it runs it will
run to completion you may have the
problem wrong but like it will run and
it won't just fail out
um another thing you can get out of this
actually is just remove the top bit
entirely and if you are dealing with a
set of table or set of tables that you
know have data appended to them all the
time but the schema doesn't change very
often you can just Define the table on
the ibicide say here are the column
names here are the types build up your
expression compile it ship it over
execute it get it back right so there's
a couple of ways to do this but how can
we do this in a reliable way no because
otherwise this is worth nothing
um and the answer is like some really
strong typing and really good validation
so sort of a quick peek at what that
looks like
we validate Expressions at construction
time not at execution time so if you
have here a Table ratings it has three
columns has they're all strings and you
try to say check for where the number of
votes is greater than a hundred well
because num votes is currently a string
and string greater than 100 doesn't make
a whole lot of sense that's just going
to come back and tell you you can't do
that those those types aren't compatible
for this kind of operation right and if
you then cast it to an integer and then
do the same thing then you sort of get
this representative expression that sort
of letting you know like yeah we will
totally do that when you tell us to run
it
um and again this doesn't mean that your
query is correct but it doesn't mean
that your query will execute uh which is
like a nice guarantee to have
so demo time we'll see how this goes
all right
um is that big enough everybody
yeah great is it too big
no all right we're doing great then okay
so I'm going to import ivis
I'm going to
get into the correct environment so
I'm going to import Ibis
and I'm also going to import this
underscore operator I promise I'll tell
you what that's about later but for now
just pretend it's not there and I'm
going to connect to a local database
file I have I'm using duckdb here I like
Duck DB but um it could be lots of
things
um so I've got a connection now
and now I'm just going to list the
tables that are available in this
database file I have so I've got Basics
ratings movie lens I'm going to pull out
Basics and ratings so I can just say
um
give me the ratings table I can say give
me the basics table
um and now I have these sort of
representations as Alchemy tables this
is using SQL Alchemy to kind of do some
of the translation so you see there's
some columns there's some types A lot of
strings
um and I could for instance just as a
quick thing I could execute this ratings
table and I'll limit it so it doesn't
you know just do too much right now and
this is basically saying select star
from ratings and show me the first 10.
and there's the first time great
um this comes back as a panda's data
frame by default so now you're in Panda
land you can do what you want
um or if you wanted to say take it out
as a pi Arrow table you can do that too
same thing now it's Pi Arrow you can get
a pi Arrow record batch reader if you
want to iterate over a lot of stuff even
if you're on an island Ibis is a bird it
can fly so you can you know talk to
other stuff
um for the purposes of a live demo I'm
going to turn interactive mode to true
what this means is every time that I hit
enter instead of showing you that
deferred expression we're going to
execute basically the same thing I did
like a limit 10 just as much as we need
to show you what's happening so you're
not just looking at a bunch of kind of
abstract representation of the query
so now if I look at ratings you've got a
nice table formatted with Rich use the
same data data types if I look at Basics
same deal there's some data there
um so let's start with the thing we're
looking at there's those ratings there's
the num votes and there's the average
rating we want to make those the right
types so we could say ratings dot select
and we want to say that the average
rating should be equal to ratings dot
average rating we want to cast that to a
float
right that was easy
um and then let's say we also want to
say that the num votes is equal to the
number of votes
and that will cast to an it
and we'll use the right kind of quotes
great that was easy and then we probably
want that t const value because that's
the key we're going to join on later so
I'm going to stick it in there too so
here's our cleanup table this is just
executing a couple lines just to show
you this but um it's easy to get the
rest out so I'm just going to save that
into
a variable named ratings because I am
going to overwrite it and I'm just going
to quickly Define a little toggle
function so I can toggle in it out of
interactive mode easily because
otherwise it's going to get tricky so
this is what ratings looks like if it's
not being executed right you have the
the three columns of the table and then
we are selecting three columns and two
of those are casts so we get the right
data type out so that's where the
representation of this thing
let's go back into interactive mode look
at Basics Basics has more columns and
will fit in a zoomed in screen so we can
quickly see what the names are T cons
that's that join key title type primary
type original title is adult start your
end here runtime in its genres we will
grab some of those um it's always good
when you're looking at a data set to
kind of just poke around though right so
like what do we have in title type
and a bunch of things let's say we want
to only look at movies because we're
building some kind of movie
recommendation engine or something
um so I see movie and I see TV movie so
we'll probably grab both of those out
um whenever you have something like is
adult like it's supposed to be like a
binary column you might want to check
that there are actually only two values
in there and there are so that's great
we'll make this family friendly so we'll
filter out the adult films
um and then let's see what's in genres
because it's always nice to know kind of
what extra information we have
junk so we'll drop that that's great to
know
um so let's get started cleaning this up
right so first thing we might do is
um do a filter
and say we want the title type to be one
of movie or TV movie
okay it's pretty straightforward
uh and then let's say we want to also
also add that second filter which is
that the um is adult field is equal to
zero
and that broke because remember is adult
is defined as a string right now and I
said or equal to zero you can't compare
strings integers this didn't execute I
stopped me before it built the
expression it said you're trying to
compare two things that don't really
talk to each other very well so the easy
thing to do here and probably actually
the more performant in this case is just
to compare it to a zero string instead
and that works just fine
um
right and then what do we need to do
well we want to probably select out the
columns that we now need because we can
drop some stuff that's no longer sort of
you know important here so we'll grab
t-cons because we want to join on that
we'll grab the primary title I don't
really care about the title type anymore
we've got our movies
we don't need the is adult flag anymore
because we've already filtered on that
and maybe I'll grab the um
maybe I'll grab those two actually
that's fine
all right so there are our movies
and now we could um save this
into basics
and I'll toggle off interactive mode and
let's just take a quick look at what
this looks like and it is too big to see
but let me just jump up a bit and so
this is a little more uh not complicated
just longer there are more columns in
the first place but here's the original
table
and then we're selecting some things we
have some predicates here so it doesn't
contain movie and TV movie is the adult
field equal to zero and then we're just
selecting out some columns at the end of
that so that's sort of what is in
ratings
okay
um and so now we probably want to stick
those two things together so we can
actually use them right so we wanted to
say uh take Basics and join that to
ratings on the T key the key t const
um and I'll turn interactive mode back
on
sweet that's easy like there's our
movies and there's our ratings and we're
good except we probably want to like
show people specific movies like maybe
based on rating and how they're doing so
we probably want to do then is order
that by the oh here comes the underscore
the average rating
so the underscore in this case uh always
refers to the previous expression right
I just joined one table to another table
saying average rating is now a little
bit ambiguous if I'm saying
basics.average rating or ratings that
average rating like where did it come
from it's a little bit hard to resolve
that so if you just want to say look at
the previous thing please and then use
that column this is a shortcut you could
do the same thing with a Lambda function
this is just faster to type
um so this is saying join those in order
by average rating
and I haven't heard of any of these
movies but that's because I forgot how
ratings work and the usually the higher
number is better so we will make this
descending instead
I'm not going to do that yet thank you
okay and I still haven't heard of any of
these movies uh because we probably
don't want to treat a movie with a
rating of 10 that has eight votes the
same as a movie with a rating of 10 that
has 100 000 votes
so why don't we go ahead and filter out
um movies that have numb votes greater
than a thousand so we want to make sure
you have at least a thousand votes to be
included in our list here
um I still haven't heard of any of these
movies
so let's bump it up ten thousand
there's the Shawshank Redemption of The
Godfather so we're on the right track I
don't know what CM 101 mmxi fundamentals
is so we're going to go a little higher
up sorry if that's your favorite movie
no offense
um
and let's say a hundred thousand
and that looks I think that looks pretty
much like the top 10 on IMDb there might
be some slight differences but that
seems like a reasonable I've heard of
these I've seen a bunch of them so
that's you know a little bit of like
kind of just you know uh
checking our our intuition here
so why don't we scroll that away in top
films
because that is our list of top films so
we can look at top films we'll execute
I'll toggle this off again and we'll see
that that top films uh representation if
we're not executing it in real time
is again
not that hard to really look through I
mean it's the same tables we had right
we had ratings we had Basics
remember that on the basics we were
filtering on the title type and the
taking out the adult stuff
remember that in the ratings we were
doing the casts to make sure the data
types match what we expect and then we
did a join and then remember that after
that join we just wanted to make sure
that the number of votes was greater
than a hundred thousand and that the uh
the sword order should be the average
rating in descending order right so
that's the whole thing
um so one really cool thing about this
though is that this is this abstract
representation right there's nothing
about this that says run on Duck DB it
just says run this on something that has
columns that have these names and these
data types that's what we have here so
if I have a different connection say to
like a postgres instance I can execute
the same thing
and have a limit of 10 and I will get
back uh let me make that a little bigger
now
because otherwise you really aren't
going to believe me aren't you
there's those movies right
um and if I if I wanted to say have a
third connection to like a local sqlite
database
then I can do the same thing right so
long as the underlying database has
those column names and those types you
can execute this and you'll see that
there are actually some slight
differences in the results here and
that's because like I didn't like really
uh constrain the query tightly enough to
make sure that I'm getting back the same
answers every time I could also add like
an order by on the number of votes and I
would get the same thing back but you're
subject to like slight sorting
mismatches on like you know something's
out of core something's doing something
in Threads you get slightly different
answers they're all correct based on the
query I gave them my query is under
specified
um and then just to kind of prove that
we can do this
um I was saying like you know what if
you wanted to then have a bunch of
queries that you were also then
filtering on certain keywords so you can
do that you can say like hey for these
pairs of keywords yield me a filter on
that table I pass in
that is looking for the title having
either this keyword or that keyword
right
and so I could say then
um
oop I could say something
uh like you know get the queries from
that top films and let me turn
interactive mode back on for this so we
see something we can use one just start
going through them right I mean I could
first validate all these but there's you
know movies that have either laundry or
Samurai in them and there's top films
that have the word fight or whatever the
other keyword was in there so you can
imagine that you could just have even
like a generator or a list of queries
that are just these abstract
representations and then you can first
off if you get the list back in the
first place congratulations all your
queries are valid at least and then just
churn through them and execute them all
um
cool all right so I'm going to stop live
demo there I think we'll go back here
let's recap what just happened
um so I showed you we did some selects
and filters some aggregations some joins
Ibis lets you easily combine expressions
and you can Target multiple back ends
whether they're local or remote for a
live demo they're all local because I'm
not like relying on snowflake being able
to hit it on conference Wi-Fi but again
you can run these anywhere that Ibis
supports
um some other things I didn't show you
but they're worth mentioning sometimes
you really need to write SQL right maybe
Ibis doesn't expose something or you
know how to spell this really specific
operation in SQL or someone you work
with knows how to spell something
specific in SQL and you want to use it
we have an escape patch called dot SQL
that will let you write just string SQL
you know the query and it will execute
it and store that in the expression this
is actually still deferred we do some
cool stuff to make that happen in this
case we're not saving you from the
dialect differences like you have to
know the dialect you're writing to
because we're passing this straight
through the engine so we can't we're not
kind of saving you from those little
mismatches but you can do this it's an
option and one cool thing about this is
that this doesn't mean you're stuck in
SQL land now you could then say go back
to Ibis land chaining that so this is
like I'm uh doing the cast on average
rating in SQL but then I can do the cast
on numb votes in Ibis
and then I can even Alias that to a
different name and then go back to SQL
and select them out and rename them and
you I mean I don't recommend doing this
but you can and you can ping bong back
and forth so if you're working with
somebody like a data engineer who really
knows their stuff and has like hey
here's how you get the view for this
like crazy table you build everything
off of Step One Dot SQL thing and now
you're in Python land and you can go
from there you're not like bound to stay
in SQL just because that was your
starting point
um I've also been talking a lot about
SQL uh but it's not only SQL and Ibis so
we actually have uh other backends that
are non-sql back ends but you can use
the same Expressions to execute against
them
um so this again remember this just a
simple example of the ratings and casts
and stuff here's that expression
um for an alchemy table against duck DB
so you've seen this a couple times now
just the columns and then the selection
rules this is what it looks like if you
want to execute against pandas
the only difference is at the top it
says Panda's table instead of alchemy
table
if you want to execute into polars the
only difference is it says database
table instead of pandas table or alchemy
table
right this thing's going to execute the
same
and so where can you execute all this
stuff in lots of places I'm going to
read a lot of names now clickhouse Das
data Fusion duct TB Impala MySQL pandas
polars posters Pi spark snowflake sqlite
we also have third party back ends for
bigquery and heavy AI which used to be
called omnis idb
Snowflake and polars are new in 4.0 and
that is coming out in probably January
where you can try it out on the main
branch right now
um so I would propose that Ibis is a way
for you to scale from Dev to prod with
less rewriting uh I'm saying less
rewriting because there are no golden
tickets here like floating Point math
exists right it's uh it isn't
associative so like any engine is going
to do something slightly different and
you may get slightly different results
um you just need to be aware of that
like when you're running these things
like you're going to get slightly
different results if you have a bunch of
chained mathematical operations just
check your answers right
um some things are inherently back end
specific so for instance you can't use
dot SQL on polars because polars doesn't
speak SQL I don't think we can't pass it
through to the underlying engine
um and then there's some back-end
differences that either can't be or we
just have not abstracted away because
it's really hard or just intractable so
like it seems like every SQL engine has
its own special regular expression
dialect and we do not yet have a magical
library to translate between regular
expression dialects if somebody does
please talk to us we will be very happy
to incorporate it
um but having said all of that
um like I think it will definitely be
less work than rewriting pandas's spark
data frame right there's a there's a
little bit of extra work to do if you're
moving around between back ends but like
it should be pretty straightforward
so what's next for Ibis
um we're going to add additional targets
for query results uh more options for
query output formats we've got piaro and
pandas right now we're going to add a
bunch more stuff uh work on our logical
plan optimizations so that if you look
at generated SQL which I forgot to show
you I'll show you that in a second you
can kind of see what it looks like and
it'll be much more concise
um some extra ux improvements and
seriously like your request here like we
are interested in user feedback try it
out tell us what's great tell us what
you wish was different what you want we
are on the internet all the time and we
will listen to you
um
really quickly I just didn't show you
this
um you can show SQL of a query like
ratings and that's that query in
postgresql
or if you wanted it in SQL Lite
you can do that too
now so that's actually getting shipped
over the wire when we send it to the
engine so if you ever need to examine it
first to make sure it's doing something
not insane it's right there and with
that I have got some time to take
questions and then just quickly here's
where you can find us on the internet
all those places and a special note my
colleague Philip cloud has a great
YouTube channel called Philip in the
cloud and every Monday I was streaming
like kind of live demos and or new
features in Ibis so if you want a quick
way to see what's going on and also how
to use it and some cool problems working
on uh check that out and here are all of
the ways to install it
foreign
so the question for uh recording is like
you know how pie in the sky is the idea
of taking existing SQL query and then
translating it into Ibis python
automatically so we are working on that
it's not pie in the sky I mean it sounds
crazy but um we're close so we can take
existing SQL uh parse it and translate
it into an Ibis expression already and
so the trick then is to go from the Ibis
expression into a sort of Quine that
will give you the python code that would
have generated that Ibis expression and
it's that last bit that we're working on
uh but it's within reach and once we
have it like yeah do you want to
translate your entire SQL existing SQL
base into like python code instead like
yes you can do that soon
here under I'm gonna say under a year
under a year I uh I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna waffle a lot now um I think we
could have it in a couple of months we
have a prototype that works for a bunch
of stuff uh we won't ship it until it's
pretty reliable
but you could probably try it out soon
there's a PR open
um uh yes you how do you think about um
what do you do that is a great question
so the question is like what do we do
about about our performance
considerations and like how do we
provide hints uh and the answer is we
don't worry about it very much um we we
definitely try to optimize the SQL we're
generating to at least not have a whole
bunch of extra projections and stuff we
are really relying on the back end so
like these queries the data I'm using in
the samples here are like not so huge
that you see this but like Duck DB is
going to be orders of magnitude faster
than SQL 8 because duck DB has an
amazing Optimizer and postgres is an
amazing Optimizer so we're really we're
relying on the engines themselves to
handle those optimizations for things
like hints that's where dot SQL comes in
because it's always some wacky common
syntax it isn't part of the standard you
have to fit in
um Jesse over there
um
totally so the question is can you do
this for like parquet files that are
stored in S3 and the answer is yes
um that we will have restrictions on
back end because the back end needs to
know how to ingest that thing but for
instance for uh we actually just merged
yesterday do ibis.read and give it the
S3 path to the parquet file and you'll
get back an Ibis table that is linked to
the a link to duckdb and it will only
pull down it'll do the push it'll do
push Downs for you so it only grab the
columns you need to run your query but
yeah you can register csvs tsvs parquet
files compressed CSV compressed tsv I'm
missing some other stuff lots of stuff
yeah yes
can you also do like indication of your
data like updates
great question can you do a mutation of
the data updates and deletes
sometimes
um the that that right now that is
something which is I would say not well
unified among all the back ends kind of
depending on when they were added what
was the main idea we're working on one
of our other big pushes aside from the
ibiscoin thing is to have a like a
well-defined set of like apis and rules
around ddl stuff so that we can be
consistent and predictable in the way
that these things happen so it's it's
possible but sometimes a little janky
no yeah
it's a limitation on
how much data and
um is there a limitation on how much
data Ibis can handle
the only limitation because again the
execution is happening on the engine
right so that might be on your laptop or
it might be you know some huge monster
like snowflake instance or something the
limitation would be if you want to pull
the results back and you want all of
them and they're like you're going to
get back an in-memory data frame if you
ask for a panda's data frame if that is
more RAM than your laptop has then
you're done
but you could still instead ask for that
back as like an iterator of pyro batches
or something and then you could you know
stream through them and do it so the
short answer is no and the longer answer
is sometimes
yeah
um yeah right there
okay
um so is there a way for let's say you
have like a really complex kind of like
final functioning
well there are any concepts like udfs
and stuff that you can use with the yeah
so the question is what about udfs
what about udfs um we have UDF support
for the pandas and the dasc back ends
um that is the third big thing we're
working on uh how do you unify UDF
Behavior every SQL engine has like a
different way to spell udfs or a
different language it wants them in and
we are working with several
um people who work on these engines to
try to figure out what is a sane way to
represent those informations that we can
translate this and also have it still be
performing we could always like pickle
something and send it over but if you
run that in like Duck DB I don't think
it's going to be super fast so
open question
yeah so we're doing some pretty standard
SQL stuff yeah about things like
um window functions cubes I mean all the
stuff you want to do in in analytics
yeah great question uh like what about
the stuff that's harder than what I did
in the live demo because I have to type
live
um yes we absolutely support window
functions uh like roll ups we've got you
know all that stuff is there you can
have you know we support uh different
ranges for the proceeding and the um
what's the opposite proceeding following
Windows you can definitely do all of
that is all available
um we even sort of try to translate the
window functions into Panda stuff that
doesn't always work great but for the
SQL back ends it's definitely there
yes is there any consideration around
when you look at the actual sequel
generated zero one value
great means for humans who are reading
it is there any consideration of using
the variable names that were defined in
the
oh that's a cool idea yeah so I mean
we're we're dispatching for most of the
SQL generation right now uh to SQL
Alchemy uh we also use SQL Glock which
is a really cool too tool
um
yeah I mean our our
obviously our general hope is that you
don't have to look at the sequel but I
think that that's that's a good idea we
could pull out some better names for it
right now though it's what's being
automatically generated so we've got
like an iterator and T and it adds up so
yeah that's definitely something we
could work on
sorry the question was can we make the
Alias names for the generated like
tables and Views better
yes over there
and
um
totally yeah so the question is like
what's like like what's the overhead of
using Ibis since we're adding this
compilation validation step in there
before we then actually run that SQL
against the engine
um it'll depend on your laptop but the
answer is not a lot I mean and it should
also be
um it's a constant time thing it's about
like one and a half seconds
to you know I mean and the other thing
too is like if you had a query that you
an expression that was made up of like
thousands of Transformations it might
start to lag a little bit but I I don't
like it's unlikely I think you're gonna
end up in that place
um so it's usually constant time and
especially for any query of note it's
going to be completely lost in the noise
of the actual kind of time to perform
like the big thing you're doing
oh no sorry it's completely it
completely irrespective of the size of
the data on the other side it's just to
take the expression that's in Python and
compile it into a SQL string that we can
ship across so it has no no impact uh
the data data size has no impact on
compilation time
yes
so first of all I think I'm a big fan of
Ibis
yeah and uh
for example
sorry just for judges the
uh
another thing is
mm-hmm
all these things are like if you want to
yes
like different behaviors I really hope
you can like make this type of figures
more consistent
it's free with this thank you
okay so the first thing he said was he's
a big fan of Ibis
um and then the second thing
um was uh a request to say that can Ibis
sort of make consistent behavior of like
the things that are not consistent right
now like null comparison Behavior Uh how
group eyes behave how order buys behave
um I'll say that for the SQL side of the
engines we are doing what we can
um it is
currently hard to make some of those
rules be respected in pandas although I
think pandas just added the thing which
like lets you separate nands and nulls
so once that's more standard we can
start to approach consistency there but
so long as nands and nulls are basically
the same thing or there are enough like
people using pandas with that we're not
really able to overcome that because we
actually need the semantic difference
between those two ideas like one of
those things is definitely a number sort
of and the other one isn't so
yes
leading up of that a little bit Yeah so
obviously you've got the sequel like
engines yes technician engines and then
you have the other holders yes
what how are you thinking about keeping
those consistent they offer very
different types of operations some of
them are similar from an analytics
perspective at the end of the day
translation is very different in the way
they express those
what represents an execution engine that
is eligible to be included in here and
how do you think about consistency
okay so what's eligible to be included
in Ibis as an execution engine and how
do we think about keeping consistency
between how an Ibis expression then gets
executed on that engine eligibility
um I'm not gonna like if someone opens a
PR with their like adding their back end
that's a great way to be eligible
um really great yeah it's um
around features to make it into this
platform we are yeah I mean if somebody
if someone someone came to us to the
engine that only supported like select
statements I don't think we would we
would let that passed um I wouldn't say
there's like a strict governance uh you
know uh document around that just yet we
have a table on the website which is it
really really long and sometimes hard to
look at which will show you for instance
like we have support for geospatial
operations that only works in uh
postgres and maybe one at MySQL or
something
um but you can see like where the gaps
are between them because yes some
engines can do things that other engines
can't
um if it's in there our general feeling
is like certainly for what I would think
of as being like encompassed by like I
don't have a good worth this normal
standard sequel like don't do crazy
stuff
um that is that is uniform across all of
them there are definitely spots where if
you get onto the edges and the fringes
like things will like and what happens
is I will just tell you that operation
is not implemented for this back end so
again we'll at least tell you we can't
do it before you try to run it on the
thing
um and we're always like looking to
expand those things if it's just linked
to the appropriate like a compute node
thing and whatever engine We'll add that
in no problem if it's some fundamental
difference about what an operation means
or it just isn't present on the actual
execution engine then we can't we're not
yet going in and adding those to the
execution engine so that it matches up
all right
[Applause]